hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter Theory today
we're going to be discussing every
single subject taught at Hogwarts School
of Witchcraft and Wizardry I covered
this topic a few years ago but then it
occurred to me that with new
Publications on wizardingworld.com as
well as new game content the list
probably needed updating which it did
this also gives me an opportunity to
expand on existing subjects further
before we get going see if you can
comment all of the subjects down below
no cheating anyway I won't dawdle any
longer here are the 25 subjects of
Hogwarts core classes 1. astronomy
astronomy classes take place in the
astronomy Tower and are taught by
Professor Aurora sinistra much like in
the Muggle World these astronomy lessons
surround the observations of the night
sky via telescopes homework for this
class involves learning the names of
stars constellations and planets as well
as the location movements and
environments astronomy is a natural
science that studies celestial objects
and phenomena it uses mathematics
physics and chemistry in order to
explain their origin and evolution
objects of Interest include planets
moons Stars nebula galaxies and comets
as magical concepts are not necessarily
applicable in this class the subject
doesn't deviate much from the Muggle
version of the subject astronomy is a
required class for the first five years
of study and is optional in the last two
two charms charms are spells that add
different properties to objects or
individuals in this class students learn
various incantations wand movements and
the proper concentration needed to cast
a wide range of spells these spells can
include levitation summoning objects
creating protective enchantments and
more jumps classes are notoriously noisy
and care chaotic and the lessons are
very practical you may remember the it's
Lefty Osa not Leviosa seen between Ron
and Hermione which occurred in charm's
class glasses are held in the Chum's
Corridor and the subject is taught by
the cheerful and talented Professor
philius Flitwick 3. defense against the
dark arts defense against the dark arts
Dada is a class that teaches students
techniques to defend themselves against
dark creatures curses and other
malicious magic the curriculum covers a
wide range of topics including
recognized and repelling dark creatures
identifying and countering curses and
learning new protective spells Dada is
considered an essential subject for
young witches and wizards due to the
potential dangers they may face in the
magical world the turnover for
instructors in the subject is extremely
high with no professors lasting more
than one consecutive school year this is
because Voldemort cursed the role after
being rejected the position by Albus
Dumbledore some notable professors of
this subject include Snape Lockhart and
Remus lupine 4. herbology apology is the
study of magical plants and fungi
including their care uses and properties
students learn to identify various
magical plants understand their growth
in care requirements and recognize the
potential dangers associated with some
species they also studied the many
applications of magical plants in potion
making spell casting and other areas of
magic herbology classes are held in the
Hogwarts greenhouses and the subject is
taught by the knowledgeable and
nurturing Professor pomonas Sprout
though herbology is a magical subject
that deals with magical plants and
materials it's also worth noting that
the Hogwarts greenhouses also house
muggle plants which makes this subject
doubly useful 5. History of Magic the
history of magic class involves the
study of magical history including
important events people and discoveries
students learn about the founding of
Hogwarts the history of the Wizarding
World the evolution of magical goals and
the lives of famous witches and wizards
the subject provides a comprehensive
understanding of the magical world's
past which helps students appreciate the
context for their magical education at
least that is the desired outcome
typically the professor for this class
Cuthbert bins falls short on his
delivery his lessons are described as
being immensely boring involving only
lectures given without pause about
significant events in Wizarding history
interestingly Professor Cuthbert bins is
actually a ghost this is because when he
died he simply got up and continued
teaching as if nothing had changed
reading materials include a history of
magic written by Matilda bankshot 6.
potions potions is the art of creating
magical concoctions and elixirs by using
various ingredients students learn to
brew a wide range of potions from simple
remedies like the cure for boils to more
complex and Powerful mixtures like the
Polyjuice Potion they also study the
properties of various magical
ingredients and learn the precise
techniques required for successful
potion making potion making is a very
methodical process that requires the
correct mixing and stirring of
ingredients at the right times and
temperatures potions classes are held in
the Hogwarts dungeons notable professors
include Severus Snape and later Horus
Slughorn 7. Transfiguration
Transfiguration is a very broad branch
of magic that deals with the changing
form and appearance of objects animals
and people students learn a variety of
spells and techniques to transform one
thing into another as they progress
students tackle more complex and
challenging Transformations including
human Transfiguration and conjuration
it's worth noting that it's a heavily
theory-based subject that involves a
multitude of skill sets limitations on
Transfiguration are outlined by gamp's
law of Elemental Transfiguration notable
professors include Hogwarts Headmaster
Albus Dumbledore who was an expert in
the field as well as Professor Minerva
McGonagall eight care of magical
creatures and care of magical creatures
is an elective subject that teaches
students about various magical creatures
their habits and how to care for them
the curriculum covers a wide range of
creatures from relatively harmless ones
like Flubber worms and bowtractles two
more dangerous species like hippogriffs
and blast ended screws students learn to
identify handle and care for these
creatures as well as understand their
roles in the magical world classes are
held Outdoors often in the Hogwarts
grounds or the Forbidden Forest and the
subject is taught by the enthusiastic
and passionate Professor rubius hangrid
other notable professors include
Wilhelmina grubbly Plank and Sylvanas
kettleburn 9. divination divination is
an elective subject that introduces
students to the practice of predicting
the future using various magical methods
the subject covers a range of divination
techniques including Tea Leaf reading
fire Omens crystal balls palmistry
cartomancy astrology and dream
interpretations students also learn
about the history and theory of
divination as well as limitations and
controversies surrounding its practice
divination receives considerable
scrutiny from other professors and its
legitimacy is constantly in question it
is described by Professor McGonagall as
one of the most imprecise branches of
magic glasses are held in a classroom at
the top of the North Tower filled with
mystical and Atmospheric decorations
notable professors include The Eccentric
and dramatic Professor Sybil trolloni as
well as the centaur forenze 10. Muckle
studies Muckle studies is an elective
subject that teaches students about the
non-magical world its culture and its
technology students learn to understand
and appreciate the differences between
the magical and non-magical worlds as
well as the importance of maintaining
the international statute of Wizarding
secrecy the class was taught by
Professor charity Burbidge and a very
different version of it was later taught
by electrocaro this overarching subject
can be sub-categorized in 2 11 muggle
art muggle art is an extracurricular
subject at Hogwarts that teaches
students about the various forms of
non-magical art such as painting drawing
sculpture and photography the curriculum
covers a wide range of topics including
art history artistic techniques and the
exploration of different mediums and
styles students learn to appreciate the
creativity and skill involved in muggle
Arts as well as how it differs from
magical art which often includes
enchantments and moving elements 12.
muggle music muggle music is another
extracurricular subject at Hogwarts that
focuses on the study and practice of
non-magical Music students learn about
various genres Styles and eras of muggle
music as well as the instruments and
techniques used to create it the
curriculum covers topics such as music
theory composition and performance
allowing students to develop their
musical abilities and appreciation for
muggle music 13. study of ancient runes
a study for ancient runes is an elective
subject that focuses on the study of
ancient magical scripts and languages
students learn to read translate and
interpret various runic texts as well as
understand the magical properties and
uses of runes in spell casting and
enchantments the subject provides a
deeper understanding of the magical
world's history and the development of
magical knowledge study of ancient runes
classes are held in a classroom in the
ancient runes Corridor and the subject
is taught by
babbling 14. arithmancy arithmancy is an
elective subject at Hogwarts that
teaches students about the magical
properties of numbers and the use of
numerology in spellcasting and
divination the curriculum covers topics
such as number symbolism mathematical
equations and the relationships between
numbers and magical phenomena it's
Hermione's favorite subject and there is
an advanced offering for the class the
class is taught by Septima vector and is
held in classroom 7A on the Hogwarts
Castle's seventh floor 15. Alchemy
Alchemy is an advanced and sort of
composite subject which mixes
Transfiguration potions and muggle
chemistry it teaches students about the
disciplines of an ancient magic the
study of the four basic elements via
earth water air and how to manipulate
them for the purpose of transmuting
substances students also learn about the
history of alchemy its influence on
magical knowledge and the techniques
require mind to perform successful
transmutations it's worth mentioning
that Alchemy isn't taught to everyone
with wizardingworld.com stating that
only some students are allowed to study
Alchemy and receive special instruction
other classes 16. dark arts not to be
confused with defense against the dark
arts dark arts was a rather taboo
subject which was mandatory for all
students during the 1997 to 1998 school
year it replaced defense against the
dark arts that year the subject focuses
on the study and practice of Dark Magic
including the use of cursors hexes and
jinxers as well as the control and
manipulation of dark creatures students
are taught to embrace the power of dark
magic often using it to inflict harm and
control others Amicus Caro is the
professor 17. flying flying teaches
students the basics of broomstick flying
and control the curriculum covers topics
such as proper mounting techniques about
balance steering and speed control as
well as the rules and regulations
surrounding broomstick use in the
Wizarding World students learn to master
their flying skills which are essential
for various magical activities such as
playing quidditch or traveling by
broomstick flying classes are held
outdoors in the Hogwarts grounds and the
subject is taught by Madame Rolanda huge
who is also the referee for Hogwarts
quidditch matches it's worth noting that
this class does not teach unsupported
flight AKA flight without the use of a
broomstick
extracurricular subjects 18 ancient
studies ancient studies is an elective
subject to Hogwarts that focuses on the
history culture and magical practices of
ancient civilizations the curriculum
covers topics such as ancient Egyptian
Greek and Roman magic as well as the
study of historical artifacts magical
customs and early forms of spellcasting
students gain a deeper understanding of
the roots of modern magical knowledge
and the development of magical societies
19. art art is an extracurricular
subject at Hogwarts that allows students
to explore their creativity through
various forms of visual expression
including painting drawing and sculpture
a distinction should be made between art
and muggle art as the ordinary art class
bears magical undertones remember
magical portraits they use magical paint
in this class students learn to develop
their artistic abilities and appreciate
the role of Art in magical culture 20.
field studies field studies is an
extracurricular subject at Hogwarts that
encourages students to explore the
magical world through Hands-On
experiences and outdoor activities the
curriculum covers topics such as magical
creatures magical plants and various
magical locations students learn to
apply their magical knowledge in real
world situations and gain a better
understanding of the magical world
through direct Ops observation and
interaction field Studies classes are
held outdoors and may be led by various
Hogwarts professors depending on the
specific area of focus this is a
relatively new subject introduced in
2010 21 ghoul studies ghoul studies is
an elective subject at Hogwarts that
teaches students about ghouls a category
of magical creature that includes
vampires and poltergeists the curriculum
covers topics such as ghoul biology
behavior and habitat as well as methods
for dealing with ghouls and
understanding their role in magical
folklore students learn to identify
interact with and manage goals in a safe
and responsible manner the class is
taught in the serpentine Corridor
located in the Hogwarts Terrace Magnus
22. magical Theory magical theory is a
subject of Hogwarts that provides
students with a foundational
understanding of the principles and
mechanics of magic taking a look at
Magic from a theoretical standpoint the
curriculum covers topics such as the
nature of magical power the laws
governing magical energy and the
theoretical basis for spell casting and
potion making with this class students
learn the underlying Concepts that
inform their practical magical education
and develop a deeper appreciation for
the complexity of magic reading
materials for this class include the
book magical Theory 23 music not to be
confused with muggle music music is an
extracurricular subject at Hogwarts that
teaches students the fundamentals of
magical music including the study of
magical instruments Enchanted
compositions and the role of Music in
magical culture the curriculum covers
topics such as music theory composition
and performance allowing students to
develop their musical abilities and
appreciation for magical music
24. xylomancy xylomancy is an elective
subject at Hogwarts that teaches
students the art of divination using
twigs and wooden objects it is
considered to be often overlooked the
curriculum covers topics such as the
symbolism of different types of wood the
interpretation of twig formations and
the application of xylomancy in
predicting future events or
understanding the present 25 Apparition
operation is an optional 12-week
specialized class at Hogwarts that
teaches students the magical skill of
teleportation allowing them to instantly
transport themselves from one location
to another the class is only available
to students who are 17 years old or
older the curriculum covers topics such
as the 3DS of apparition destination
determination and deliberation which are
essential for successful Apparition
students learn to visualize their design
destination Focus their determination on
reaching that location and deliberately
execute the necessary magical steps to
achieve Apparition a Apparition classes
are typically held in a large open space
within Hogwarts such as the Great Hall
to provide ample room for students to
practice their skills the class is
taught by Ministry of magic Apparition
instructor who is specially trained and
certified to teach this Advanced magical
skill in the series Wilkie twycross is
The Apparition instructor who comes to
Hogwarts to teach the students and that
concludes all of the classes taught at
Hogwarts however what's also worth
diving into is the education that
students receive prior to attending hog
courts without a proper academic base
some of these classes simply wouldn't be
accessible by the time most students
have started at the magical school odds
are they've already received some level
of Education either through
homeschooling or attending muggle
primary school and it's through this
introduction to schooling and the
establishment of their foundational
knowledge that students are able to find
increased value in magical subjects
using English as an example we can link
lots of magical careers that would rely
heavily on this subject journalists for
the daily Prophet head of the aura
office politicians like the minister of
magic all of these professions would
seemingly require a higher than Primary
School knowledge of English the skill of
writing is reinforced at Hogwarts
through essay writing but it's important
to note that most of this subject matter
is magical not muggle so my thought is
that these foundational subjects are
mixed into the curriculum wherever
possible or applicable I'd imagine that
maybe they just aren't discussed because
they're not particularly exciting
whichever way you look at it some
professions are going to require maths
English and or science whether they're
magical in nature or not so it makes no
sense that students would grow into
adulthood with no knowledge of these
subjects Ganon never actually dictates
how a magical child would receive
Advanced instruction in maths or science
at Hogwarts and while I don't feel that
there's necessarily A huge emphasis on
these topics in the curriculum I think
that there is perhaps more happening
behind the scenes than we are aware of
additionally I would expect that those
who desire to learn more about these
subjects would have the opportunity to
do so through apprenticeships or perhaps
in some instances through tailored
instruction
hopefully that clears up the entire
education of a Hogwarts graduate and
gives you some improved insights into
the Hogwarts curriculum if you think I
missed something please let me know down
below until next time remember it does
not do to dwell on dreams and forget to
live
[Music]
foreign